I can't rest my daughter deserves better  we all deserve better change never comes  easy  this war isn't going to win itself  all his children  it's June's legacy what changed me  change to you  she does have strong claws  [Music]  it's not safe anymore we could all just  leave these women deserve to be helped  but I can't do this alone  must be the squad  she is out there planning who knows what  kind of atrocities to visit upon our  righteous nation  I never allowed myself to see her for  what she clearly is beyond redemption  what happens in the next few weeks will  determine the future of this country  we're just getting started  [Music]